one of the group's most vulnerable in
this pandemic are the homeless South
Africa's president Sturm a poser has
promised that homes people will be
looked after during the lockdown in Cape
Town that means taking them off the
streets and putting them into a camp
which Doctors Without Borders says is
more likely to spread coronavirus and if
that stayed where they were the W's
Adrian Krrish has been to see for
himself Cape Town Mayor Dan played who
actually wanted to showcase how well his
city is dealing with the homeless during
the coronavirus crisis it has set up
shelter for some 1,500 people at a
sports field on the outskirts of the
city the mayor and his staff proudly
point out a mobile medical clinic but
the upbeat mood quickly changes when we
approach the tents where the homeless
live behind a fence some yell out that
they are dying there and have to sleep
out in the cold the police move on
South Africa has introduced one of the
toughest lockdowns in the world
that's why Cape Town is housing these
homeless they live in tents and has
served regular meals by workers in full
protective gear only those people who
can prove they have a place to stay may
leave the heavily guarded camp
you must remember and understand these
people that were really living on the
streets
some of them use drugs and use alcohol
and that sort of thing the withdrawing
some terms is figure is quite high
because they want to continue the habits
but here they can't unfortunately if you
allow these people to walk around what
do you think what will happen at the
fence the men asked us how many
coronavirus cases they are now in the
country and how many have died he says
that since his arrival he has received
any information but we have to leave me
yesterday is over the mayor said the
situation only escalated because of the
presence of so many cameras he said
normally it would be very calm and
journalists would be free to come back
to have a look any time now we've tried
for several days to get a permit from
the city to get back in but we didn't
get any response now we came here again
and we were just turned away when South
Africa registered its first coronavirus
infection in early March the government
was swift to implement measures to
combat the spread of the disease while
testing capacity and protective gear
remain an issue early figures suggest
the strict policies are working
this is McWeeny Township in the city of
power the cramped conditions mean
residents are especially vulnerable to
the coronavirus to prevent the spread of
covered 19 here and throughout South
Africa thousands of health workers are
carrying out door-to-door screening
we're just gonna ask members of the
household for any symptoms and if they
have any we don't do swabbing and stuff
like this year South Africa's Karuna
virus infections are growing slowly not
exponential but even the government is
skeptical about the official numbers the
hope is that screening can pinpoint
unknown outbreaks the country's first
covered 19 cases had traveled from
northern Italy in early March since then
South Africa has closed its borders and
bends most incoming flights South Africa
has implemented very strict measures
already after the first few cases like a
very strict lockdown in the entire
country but can these measures help to
avoid a sharp increase in the number of
cases hospitals throughout the country
are getting ready and setting up testing
stations 80% of the population depends
on the public health care system and it
was already overstretched before the
coronavirus crisis started I think we've
got all our planning ready it's the
unknown investor issues so we normally
see on average about a hundred fifty
patients a day we can probably manage up
to about 160 170 patients today it's
that unknown or am I gonna see two
hundred two hundred and fifty percent
today and then where am I gonna get my
resources from if we do jump up to that
number
it's unclear how the pandemic will
ultimately play out these days in South
Africa there's little sign of despair or
resignation in the fight against covet
90